[Music]
uk police
have helped to save a woman woman 3 000
miles away in canada cool what how'd
they do how
i like the house
wow this is why he's here
so uh
durham
or durham durham
i like their handbag
because it sounds like i'm from the
south go ahead you come from durham
they're hammers i think it's durham i
like that one
but what about if you're in the uk
not a [ __ ] number damn it's a
hamburger let me hear it
i don't know hamburg
that was really good
a city
or area that is both in canada and the
uk what [ __ ]
oh is it like up there at the top of the
ball like right there what are you
[ __ ] talking about they did a mix-up
huh is it on the west coast no i know i
mean i mean that it's just the same name
oh
no they're connected bro no no you're
right they're connected i thought you
were talking about at the really top of
the ball there's like a it's used that
the globe is the ball uk and canada like
this
check the map check the map if you don't
believe say uk in canada or america okay
check them out you realize where the
[ __ ] the uk is you guys don't ever see
you never went like this
no one's seen the top of the ball you
guys think the earth is round you guys
are all done what do you mean what
happens when you put on the top shelf
you talking about north pole maybe
nobody here but i'm pretty sure
someone's seen the top of the ball there
oh my god do they really have that
[ __ ] spinning hair hair salon thing
at the north pole
oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah the barber shop
pulled yeah yeah it's all red like a
candy but it's like it's like a long one
it's been there for at least 60 years
those are naturally reoccurring actually
all right cool yeah
they grow everything because every time
you see a [ __ ] map right in a cartoon
or whatever the north pole has the candy
cane it's always slanted though that's
like the
looney tunes
accuracies so uh last wednesday
afternoon
durham police were contacted via online
chat by a distressed woman who reported
that an intruder was trying to get into
her home in durham wait what the [ __ ]
she texted that the only issue was the
victim was referring to durham in canada
according to police the distraught
victim typed i need help
he is going to come he is in the house
before falling silent
so despite contacting a different durham
police in a different country she kept
the chat open while where officials were
able to think quick on their feet and
they're like this [ __ ] is calling from
a canadian number because you know our
brother sister durham
durham in canada yeah oh she's on one of
those websites where they're like do you
want to chat now because she couldn't
she couldn't call and use her voice oh
so she quickly tried to get yesterday
she was in the closet
and she was like something like that she
was trying to google or whatever during
police
maybe she was on her uk vpn or something
like that
doing crypto or something you know
i need a 911 text direct message thingy
i've never been on a police station
website i don't think oh have you guys
called the police station they have
facebook pages though have you called
like a direct not 9-1-1 but they're not
emergency yeah anonymous faster you call
call direct to the to the like locality
or whatever it's faster to call local
versus 911
no no but when you call
other things 911 you'll be on hold hella
long like when we're when the homeless
people are shooting on my front lawn all
the time i would call the city and then
they made it faster there was a homeless
party outside my front yard
homeless party did you what does that
mean yeah there was one guy who i told
not to sit on my steps before and he had
a guitar
oh [ __ ] what a dick he came back later
he's actually he's actually pretty nice
and then there was another guy who
actually smokes meth at the park that i
know that's right
hilo sketch he had a little lawn chair
and an umbrella and he parked out like
outside like of our yard
and these [ __ ] were chatting it
up at like nine o'clock at night so i
was like [ __ ] like i don't have to
call the [ __ ] city or whatever
emergency hotline yeah and they came and
they said hey you guys can't be here and
then they left and it was all good but
it happened very quickly it was great
yeah it's faster at a smooth experience
also isn't that pasadena no
i don't know what you're talking about
probably that's the city where i would
see them do that very nicely oh yeah
because you know it's a small city my
city was like that too and those guys
were [ __ ] on my lawn so much that
when the uh when the cops would come i
started to learn
how they dispatched how the city was
like uh district one this or two
district three district four
like how
how they would make their routes like i
understood their whole like how the [ __ ]
did you learn all that from cops coming
to pick up [ __ ] no no they'll come and
say hey you can't be like sitting here
and then i started to recognize regulars
i'm like oh cool when it's like 11
o'clock at night it's always you this
was like i know that their their routes
are at 6 30 pm they go and pick up
donuts and i'm like what the [ __ ] he has
it right now he's trying to talk because
he rode along
can i come with you to the next one he's
in the back of the homeless dude but
it's it's so freaking inefficient last
time i had to chase a homeless guy out
of the house who's broke in to take a
bath he came in and [ __ ] had a bubble
bath yeah oh my looks like you have nice
soaps did you have a [ __ ]
rubber ducky and [ __ ] no this is even
it's even worse because of this [ __ ]
animatics baths are you taking
all i'm saying is i always use rubber
duckies and it doesn't feel complete
unless there's a rubber ducky fair
enough i had to like uh so i chased them
out and then i'm calling the cops i'm on
hold forever and then finally when
someone picks up they're like oh uh
we'll we'll find wherever you are just
like
just keep following them and then we'll
find we'll find wherever you are just
keep telling us the streets so i'm just
walking with a homeless guy oh my god
for almost 45 minutes
he had it did he have his towel wrapped
around like how did you get him out
he was in your house so it's [ __ ]
sound it's even worse than it sounds now
but this is back when the house is an
airbnb
uh and i was managing it and then the
families like a nice little swedish
family was staying there they they text
me and they go who is this and then it's
a photo there's a [ __ ] naked guy in
the tub oh my god
and then there's a homeless man just
scrub-a-dub dubbing they took a picture
of him they took a picture of him he was
naked yeah he's still there naked and
everything he's like i'm almost done
give me [ __ ] because he's not homeless
homeless crazy people don't [ __ ] run
they just keep doing what they're doing
and they're not they're not all theirs
they're not
having a conversation with one of his
butlers so then i'm chasing him out
which is not really chasing but i'm just
walking behind him did you tell him so
you showed up to the house yeah so how
did you confront the dude he was already
um walking down the stairs he going like
this yeah
he already had his clothes on he's
walking down the stairs and now i'm just
on the phone with the cops and i'm
walking behind him and the cops are like
just tell us what street you're on well
well now i'm over here and 45 minutes
through hollywood i'm just walking with
this guy and then by the like after some
time like they just go actually don't
don't chase him if he gets violent it'll
be your fault
and i was like are you [ __ ] he's like
well yeah at this point you've been
following for 45 minutes so he's like
paranoid brains like the government's
fault so then they're like keep a safe
distance so then i kind of like kept a
safe distance then he goes into some
like person's backyard i can't [ __ ]
follow him anymore saying the cops
[ __ ] get there and i'm like yeah he
went over there or something like i
don't know where he's at now and they're
like uh we'll probably find him another
time they just stopped looking what a
waste of time oh that's nuts and what
sucks is they can't do anything no they
can't what are they gonna do hit em oh
what
why would you say that that's crazy yeah
why would you say that i'm really good
at ventriloquism
you need to move to pasadena because
that happened to me
right there was a guy sitting in my
front yard
and he was like nuts dude but he was
like this big he was like six five big
like white dude
and i'm pulling out i'm going to the gym
and i see this dude sitting there and
i'm like
hey
and he looks and i go you can't be
sitting there man it's my [ __ ] front
yard you got to leave
and he goes nah the lady inside said i
can stay here
right the week before
while we were here at jk news big guys
like walking in front of the front yard
and my girl was like she goes up to him
and goes hey you can't be here and he's
like talking [ __ ] to her and then she
goes back in the house so he's referring
to that instance as like she told me i
could stay here
right so he's like in his mind he thinks
your girl your girl said it was okay
yeah yeah so he's sitting in the front
and he's like talking blah blah blah and
he's like he's like i'm the real
marcellus wallace this ain't no pulp
fiction like he's just talking to
himself like that and i'm like yo this
dude is nuts oh damn that's scary i call
the cops and then the guy who pulls up
is actually one of my clients that i
train so i was like hey what's up dude
so he pulls up
yeah yeah yeah and it passes great dude
you're going to pass you become friends
with people yeah and he and then they
handled the situation and they shot him
yeah yeah
he was hey you want me to [ __ ] take
them
on the real myself
when i saw this i was actually worried i
was like i was like you're not gonna
beat this guy up or nothing right he's
like well
we'll be fine we'll be fine
choose something on my belt
and i was like this one
it's just a pepper spray okay cool but
like you know they were straight like he
was like
he was resisting but then as soon as
they grabbed them he just started
walking out and so they had to cuss them
they had to cuff him they put him in the
car and they asked me like what do you
want to do next and i was like uh what
are the like what like what are the
options yeah like electric chair
i was like the taser i guess no but in
and out man yeah yeah but they were
saying that like you could either press
charges
but then he's just gonna go get booked
if there's nothing on at least them in
two three
not even they'll release them within an
hour yeah after they find out there's
nothing there's nothing on them so there
i was like it's fine whatever just let
him go and then he left he got on my
face called me a little [ __ ]
and then he left
you little [ __ ] so you basically lost i
lost what does your cop friends do you
just told him to leave they just he came
with like two other cops they grabbed
them so they had to pull them out they
put them in the car and they were like
oh yeah this dude he's been
he's been walking up and down these
streets and then they let him go and
then never saw him again you know what
sure enough i go home tonight he's
probably gonna be there and [ __ ] i'm
wondering if like welcome home little
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
we want something to drink
cop friends
i'm wondering if it's like because we're
more we're home more now we see things
around our neighborhood or were there
always homeless people there but we
didn't know because we went to work and
we're never home
right so it's a combination of both yeah
because i'm like and also like you know
there's way it seems like there's more
homeless people now than ever there for
sure is there for sure is so control
room colleagues were able to contact
officers at durham regional police
service in the province of ontario and
after being notified canadian officers
were sent to the town of ajax where they
found a 35 year old man inside the home
suspect who refused to obey the
officer's request was tasered as a
result
and the man was arrested just 30 minutes
after his victim had contacted the wrong
police nice
boring
should have uncuffed him and let him
call her a little [ __ ]
see
that's before we take you away you want
to call this guy a little [ __ ]
and he's like okay yeah yeah
and he did this to me too
oh [ __ ] sorry my bad man and that was it
do you think that durham is just really
bored do you think they and i don't have
a lot of stuff to do
no i i honestly think it was well i mean
this situation was probably just like an
honest mistake you're like why the [ __ ]
is this canadian woman hitting us up
that's true oh you're in durham canada
that's nice of them to like go the extra
distance to figure it out literally the
extra distance that's a pretty
distressing [ __ ] is that the extra
distance though or is it like
nah that's not our jurisdiction so we
don't need it that's what i mean you
know it's like just close the laptop
you were like so [ __ ] busy like the
whole [ __ ] city was on fire and you
got a text from like the wrong city and
you were just like oh there's more
pressing things right now a lot of cops
let [ __ ] slide when they're just too
busy or they don't or they're about to
get off their shift i got let go for
some [ __ ] because the cop was like i'm
about to get off my ship i don't want to
do paperwork just go yeah they have to
do it were you like breaking into and
holding hostage woman about to kill her
though because that's different
i just had nunchucks outside of samwu
[Music]
you